capture and defend the
flags securing
c c
secure our UAV is
online securing B
friendly air strike on the
way securing
B friendly Chopper on the way be
secure we've taken the
lead
losing
Bravo
Bravo our UAV is
online our UAV is
online losing
Bravo securing
[Applause]
Alpha friendly air strike on the way
losing
C we lost
C
TG losing
B enemy UAV is Airborne losing
Bravo enemy UAV is
Airborne Alpha secure Char
secure losing
C
enemy UAV is
Airborne Ming a enemy UAV at airb Ming
a
losing a our UAV is
online securing
Bravo we lost
Alpha Tang down enemy UAV is Airborne
securing Bravo enemy UAV is
Airborne securing
B
our UAV is online enemy UAV is Airborne
secure losing B our UAV is online losing
Bravo
our UAV is
online I'm
reloading friendly Chopper on the
way half
time
domination capture and defend the flags
securing Alpha
stay
secure we've taken the lead securing
B friendly air strike on the
way enemy UAV is Airborne securing
C securing
Bravo friendly air strike on the
way our UAV is
online friendly Chopper on the way
securing
Bravo Bravo secure we're about to win
this one keep up the fire our UAV is
online losing
B securing
Charlie we off
spe our UAV is online C
secure losing
Charlie
losing
Alpha friendly air strike on the
way losing
Alpha
losing a losing
Charlie enemy UAV is Airborne losing
Alpha we lost
a enemy UAV is Airborne be
secure friendly Chopper on the way our
UAV is is online losing
Charlie enemy UAV is
Airborne we lost
C our UAV is
online enemy UAV is Airborne securing a
friendly air strike on the way losing
B Alpha
secure our UAV is
online our UAV is
online losing Bravo
losing
[Applause]
Bravo friendly air strike on the
way we off
be
our UAV is
online our UAV is
online
take securing
C friendly air strike on the way our UAV
is online friendly Chopper on the
way friendly air strike on the
way securing B
grenade enemy UAV is
Airborne losing
a enemy UAV is air
born friendly Chopper on the
way
SEC enemy UAV is
Airborne
secure
our UAV is
online mission accomplished good
[Music]
work